Hey youtubers it's Charlie, lots of Season
5 stuff happening right now.
I asked you all to submit questions in my
breakdown of the special this week so I pulled
a bunch and also since they aired the special
they've confirmed the Comic Con panel is going
to be on Friday like we thought.
So mark your calendars for Friday July 25th
from 12:20PM to 1:20PM Pacific Time.
I'll be posting a full breakdown of any footage
they show so be sure to subscribe to get everything.
There's going to be a ton of stuff happening
that week so I'm going to be making some special
Comic Con specific videos starting next week.
I'll explain the special giveaways I'll be
doing when I start posting those.
Question time, so assume spoilers for everything
up to where we are on the show right now.
Everything through Season 4.
There's not a lot of comic stuff in my answers
aside from what we've already discussed like
Hunters and Father Gabriel and some behind
the scenes filming stuff in terms of locations.
Everybody ready, here we go.
Question 1 - Alex asks, what happened to Tara's
sister, is she ever coming back?
Lilly was killed during the Governor's attack
in the aftermath.
Yes she did kill the governor, that was the
last we saw of her on screen.
It's implied that she just didn't survive
the Walker Assault that came after the survivors
took off in different directions.
They didn't say specifically if she'd been
wounded and died from that or if she shot
herself in grief or if she went into shock
from grief and walkers got to her.
Based on the look in her eyes as she shot
the Governor I'm assuming that she shot herself.
Her daughter was dead and the man she trusted
turned out to be a complete lie.
Had Tara been there with her she might have
saved Lilly, but she wasn't.
So I think Lilly didn't have anything to live
for anymore and she just wanted it to be over.
That's just my interpretation.
Question 2 - Dominique asks Once the survivors
escape Terminus, what do you think they will
do?
Depending on when they leave Terminus or escape,
I think they'll head for Alexandria.
For people that haven't read the comic, it's
basically Washington DC.
It's the place Abraham was trying to get Eugene
to.
Based on all the behind the scenes stuff people
have been posting from the set, it seems like
they're not going to get there anytime soon.
I'm hoping Season 6 turns into the road to
Alexandria.
Andrew J West's character, Gareth.
This guy.
Is a series regular this year.
Meaning he's in most of the episodes.
I'm hoping that means they'll spend a large
portion of the season at Terminus.
Question 3 - KJ asks, what did you think about
Aisha Tyler's comment about Beth becoming
Gareth's Terminus Queen?
I don't believe it, it's a funny way to think
about Beth.
She is supposed to get a lot more mature this
season.
But the only things we know about her specifically
is that she'll get her own story like the
Governor got in Season 4.
There will be like a Beth episode that will
tell the story of what happened to her after
she got kidnapped.
Most of the rumors I've seen say her story
this season will mostly take place away from
the survivors.
But eventually I think they'll be reunited.
I'd love to think of a scenario where Beth
helps them escape.
Question 4 - Ash asks do you have a theory
on how Carol and Tyreese learn about Rick
with the group being trapped?
And do you think it will be an emotional reunion?
I think they'll just arrive at Terminus after
Rick's Group gets dumped in the car.
I'm hoping it's a situation where they get
to the fence line and see Gareth's men with
guns on Rick as they're stuffing them into
the traincar.
Or they'll just somehow see something funky
going on and figure out that Terminus is a
bad place.
I don't think they'll just waltz in the front
gate and be dumped in the train car like everyone
else.
As for the actual reunion.
If they do end up going inside Terminus, yes.
Rick is probably going to have a major joy
attack when he sees Judith.
That would definitely be something to push
him over the edge and make him go crazy on
all the Termites.
Question 5 - Rose asks do you think Daryl
will be happy to see that Beth is alive when
and if they meet up with everyone again?﻿
I don't think Daryl will see Beth anytime
soon, but I think it will be like Rick seeing
baby Judith again.
Beth is definitely special to Daryl.
They had a life changing field trip together.
I think she brought him back from the dead,
emotionally speaking.
Question 6 - Galaxy Ronin asks If they're
doing flashbacks this season do you think
characters from the first two seasons, who
died, might make appearance?
I wonder if your thinking of the Morales Family.
A lot of people were hoping they'd come back
in the Season 3 finale but they never did.
I definitely think they'll be doing more flashbacks.
But usually they're just to tell character's
backstories or to deal with periods of time
the show didn't include in the regular episodes.
Like when we flashed back to the Prison, that
period was from the time between the season
3 finale and the season 4 premiere.
I think if they do a non character-specific
flashback, like a group flashback, it will
be from between seasons.
Mostly I'm just expecting character flashbacks
like Michonne's just for characters that haven't
got them yet.
Question 7 - David asks, do you think anyone
is going to buy into Gareth's new way of life
they teased?
I'd be disappointed if at least one survivor
didn't accidentally eat some of that grill
meat.
It would be funny in a really horrifying way.
I don't think we're going to see any brainwashed
survivors, I don't think the new Rick would
let that happen to anyone.
Looking at the people in this train car I
don't think any of them are so empty headed
that they'd let Gareth fill them with his
ideas.
Andrew West was teasing Gareth's philosophy
in the interview he did.
He made it sound like a pretty big deal, so
I think the show will tease us and make us
think some of the characters will drink the
kool aide.
But in the end I don't think any of them are
going to go to the darkside.
Question 8 - Fabian asks How much time will
the survivors spent on Terminus?
The whole season or just half of it?
When Andrew West was announced as a Series
Regular for Season 5 I thought that meant
they'd be spending at least half the season
there.
All the behind the scenes pictures I've seen
from the set right now make it seem like they're
on the road in different places.
In terms of episode production status I think
they're about halfway done filming episodes.
Norman Reedus posted this picture saying "Day
1" at the beginning of May, so based on a
production schedule of about one episode filmed
every 6 to 8 days, I think they're at least
8 episodes in.
There have been a lot of spoilery images of
survivors doing things on different sets.
I'm not going to post them, just because they
are kind of spoilery.
But right now I'm going to say by the mid-season
finale they'll be out of Terminus.
They could totally leave sooner though.
I think when they do it will include a lot
of fire and walkers.
Question 9 - Ant C asks What do you think
cause Glenn and Maggie's group to get put
in the train car?﻿
Yeah, they didn't really answer this in the
special.
I think that Maggie probably did a Rick thing
and freaked out after seeing something fishy.
Glenn is just as quick to action, but of the
people in that group I think Maggie would
be the first one to point a gun at the Termites.
Question 10 - Castiel asks If Beth is with
father Gabriel, do you think those 2 will
head to terminus?
or will they do a beth/FG episode like they
did at the end of season 4?"
I think Seth Gilliam's character will try
to take her somewhere else, if he really is
the Father Gabriel character it will probably
be to his church where he has supplies.
Like I said, they'll tell that Beth story
in it's own episode like the Governor's story
after Woodbury.
Question 11 - John asks Do you prefer the
comic or the show?
There's still a lot of the comic I haven't
read yet.
I typically only read along around where we
are in the show.
I try to not read ahead too far.
So I haven't read all out war or new beginning
yet.
I guess that means I prefer the show.
I started watching the show before I started
reading the comic.
It's a big difference in the way I experience
Game of Thrones, where I am way further ahead
than that show.
Question 12 - Nathan asks Charlie who do you
think will be the first survivor/ Rick's group
character to bite the dust this season?
There have been a lot of Glenn rumors, but
given how much they've stretched out the comic
story to this point, I think it's possible
that none of the main characters could die
anytime soon.
AMC has no reason to kill them off, and they
can demand that Scott Gimple keep them alive
if they really wanted to.
I mean, eventually someone will have to die,
but at this point I wouldn't be surprised
if they waited till the season 5 finale to
kill one of the survivors.
Question 13 - Code Red asks Do you think another
group may rescue the Survivors, such as the
Hilltop or the Kingdom?
I don't think we'll see anyone from the Kingdom.
That's a place near Washington DC, it doesn't
appear till after issue 100 and we're around
issue 60 in the show right now.
I think if they get any outside help it will
be from the other survivors like Carol and
Tyreese or Morgan will re-appear.
Mostly I think their escape will be because
of something they do.
I don't think it will be a deus ex machina
situation.
The Walker parade will get there eventually,
but I don't think that will be a direct cause
in their escape.
They'll probably just help create a distraction
for the Termites.
Question 14 - Nicholas asks do you ever think
Morgan will come back?
Scott Gimple said that he'd come back eventually,
but he was saying it in Season 4.
He was like, not this year, but definitely
in the future.
Technically it's the future, but I'm starting
to think that if we see him, it will be at
another big location like Alexandria.
Question 15 - Daniel asks If everyone is infected
with the Virus, how come people that get bitten
turn super fast?
The walkers have all kinds of crazy super
bacteria growing in their mouths, so when
someone gets bitten they get infected with
crazy batcteria that causes all kinds of crazy
infections that shuts down their immune systems
way faster.
So it's not really related to the walker virus.
It's just like getting a really bad infection
from an animal bite.
Question 16 - Mess Monster asks For last 16
eps in season 4 it was all about "can you
come back from during terrible things" and
know we're in season 5 what would this season
be about?
They kind of explained that this season it
was all about doing what it takes to survive.
Like are you willing to do what it takes,
do you have it in you.
That's where you get the talk about people
who are not badasses, becoming badasses.
It's all about stepping up to the challenge.
There's so many awful things I'm looking forward
to seeing Rick and the survivors do in the
name of survival.
Maybe for one of my future bonus videos I"ll
do a video for the top 10 most badass things
the survivors have done so far.
Thanks so much for submitting questions, be
sure to check the description for more Walking
Dead Links and important dates.
My next bonus video will probably be a comic
con explainer.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
You can learn all about what went down with
the new footage by clicking on this video
and you can learn all about the new season
5 characters by clicking on this video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!